the world has a way of changing
but there's one thing
that always stays the same
you miss the old life deal
every day
i used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time
but things changed
called father now
i will always be in your heart
little brian i have a gift for you
your daddy gave me this no i'm gonna
give it to you it's very
special
it's for protection
from what's coming
all right dom
what's next
no matter how fast you are
i am not to be compared to you no one
outruns their past
i am more easy you trying your
and
best
just caught up to me been a long time
[Music]
so we're up against a master thief
assassin performance driver
who is he
[Music]
jacob is dom's brother
your whole life you pushed yourself to
be faster than dawn
smarter than dumb
stronger than dawn
but could you kill him
because i'm ready if you are
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than the
lover family but you turn that into
anger there's nothing more dangerous
maybe this is the end but we're gonna go
out together you know i'd ride to the
death with you
[Music]
let's get to work
please tell me that's not a pontiac
fiero strapped to a rocket engine
impressive i know
no
no that's that's not impressive
i came here to take you down little
brother
that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane
hold on
tell me you're not thinking what i think
you're thinking there's no bridge
oh hell no
break it down
[Music]
hey guys
surprise nice clubhouse
you